[Music]
[Applause]
Albert Breer is the Monday Morning
Quarterback joining us on the program
let me start there with uh Kyler in fact
biggest difference between Kyler
Murray's contract and DeSean Watson's
contract is what
the guarantees I mean I think it's
what's obvious
um and you know what's so interesting
about this to me Dan is like that I
think there were a lot of people when
they looked at DeShaun Watson's contract
looked at it as a turning point for
players and I was sort of cautious about
that at the time because I can remember
when this happened with Kirk Cousins in
2018 and it's a similar situation that
precipitated it right like you have
multiple bidders and one team's trying
to one-up what the next team is doing
and this is what happens right like it's
the same concept as Cousins being a free
agent and when I asked around about
whether or not the cousin's deal was a a
game changer
agents teams what they all said was
it'll all depend on what happens next
and sure enough Matt Ryan signed a
conventional quarterback contract Aaron
Rodgers signed a conventional
quarterback contract and then we were
sort of back to where we had always been
and so this is sort of a sign to me that
maybe the DeSean Watson contract is
going to remain an outlier and it really
is amazing if you think about it because
like this contract adds five years of
Team control the Cardinals get five
extra years of Team control so they have
him for the next seven years
the Watson contract added zero
you know he just he got a flat raise and
the whole thing guaranteed which is
still incredible to look back at but
yeah I would say the fact that Watson's
contract is fully guaranteed is
obviously the difference isn't it
amazing DeShaun Watson's got baggage off
the field but nobody said anything about
on the field not one criticism it feels
like right it's amazing too I mean you
think about it like he played really
well
um did we look at him like Mahomes I
don't like before all of this it's not
like that far off but I don't know that
we've really he had elevated that level
where Mahomes has been where Alan seems
like he is now like it still felt like
he had maybe a step to take to get there
you know but I think it's really
reflective of what I would call the
homicization of the NFL and what I mean
by that is I think a lot of these teams
are now looking up that mountain and
saying to themselves is what we have
good enough like in other words can you
win with Joe Flacco anymore can you win
with Russell Wilson in his second year
can you win with Eli Manning anymore
that's the question I think teams are
asking themselves and it's why the Rams
move off of Jared Goff who was in his
20s who'd been to a Super Bowl who has
signed long term to go to Matthew
Stafford that's why the Niners moved off
of
um Jimmy Garoppolo who was in his 20s
signed long term and had been to a Super
Bowl to go to Trey Lance and you know
now it's why the Browns were so
desperate to get to Sean Watson to move
off of Baker Mayfield because I think
they were afraid looking at the
landscape in the AFC that marrying
themselves at Baker Mayfield long term
would make them essentially the 45-1
team in the NBA
how big is separation do you think in
Talent between DeSean Watson and Kyler
Murray
I think desean's a better player because
I think desean's more complete and you
know my feeling is in the NFL
you really what separates a quarterback
really is third and long right like so
like so much of a success for young
quarterbacks is managing the situation
around him and being good with your
personnel around him and keeping him out
of situations where he's playing from
behind or he's in third and long right
so like it's much easier to play
quarterback when you're in second and
five than one second and 20. and like
that's the one thing with DeSean is I
think we've seen him operate playing
from behind and I think we've seen him
operate
um in long-hearted situations and can
you win from the pocket in those
situations and Kyler Murray is a
fantastic player and there's a lot to
like about him and he's very difficult
to prepare for it the Cardinals are very
difficult to prepare for because they're
so different
but I just say like if you're talking
about having a quarterback who over the
next 10 years you may have to beat like
Patrick Mahomes Justin Herbert Josh
Allen consecutively you know what I mean
to get to a Super Bowl like I would
probably at this point have more trust
into Sean Watson to do that than Kyler
Murray because I think his game is a
little bit more diverse than Kyler
Murray the contract that has a bigger
impact on Lamar Jackson is it DeShaun
Watson or is it Kyler Murray
Kyler Murray because I I think
I think if DeSean Watson's contract was
going to have an impact on Lamar
then Kyler would have gotten something
similar if that makes sense to me the
Kyler Murray contract gives the Ravens
the opportunity to say well the desean's
contract's an outlier you know what I
mean like for like if the if if Kyler
had done say a five-year 235 230.5
million dollar deal fully guaranteed
there'd be no out for the Ravens anymore
because the rate the the Lamar could
just say look
Young quarterback and and
um in Cleveland got a fully guaranteed
deal Young quarterback in Arizona got a
fully guaranteed deal this is just where
things are going now this is the price
of doing business Kyle are doing a more
conventional quarterback contract that
was more along the lines of the deal
Josh Allen did last year gives the
Ravens the out now to say the DeSean
Watson contract was almost completely
circumstantial so you got to work with
us and do something that's a little bit
more conventional it won't change like
the raw dot like he's still going to get
paid and Kyler helps him because it's
another guy who's you know over that 45
million dollar Mark which I think
Lamar's now you have to go over there if
you're Baltimore
um but Kyle are not getting the full
guarantees allows the Ravens to say no
that fully guaranteed deal by Watson
that was all matter of circumstance he's
the Monday Morning Quarterback he's
Albert Breer
um the market for Jimmy Garoppolo is
uh not strong right now wow
um I like I I think that the shoulder
you know we can go through chapter and
verse what's happened with the shoulder
obviously his decision to to rehab
um and try rehab and delay things for
six or seven weeks
um back in February and March had a
profound impact on all of this and so
you know it puts the Niners in a tough
spot it puts Jimmy in a tough spot and
you know I think them getting word out
there because
I mean John Yee's had the his agent has
had the the green light to work on
financials with other teams for quite
some time now like he's been okay like
they've said it's okay if you want to go
see if there's some way you can work the
contract out because no one's going to
take on the 25 million dollars elsewhere
to help facilitate a trade we're okay
with you doing that
um yeah I think do getting the word out
there again that you're okay to go seek
a trade is to try to spark something and
I think right now they're entering a two
or two to three week window that's going
to be very very critical I think both
sides feel this way right because but
why don't they why don't the Niners seek
the trade instead of because Jimmy's
going to go hey I got this offer and
then the Niners will go no why why don't
the Niners start this so then Jimmy
doesn't have to keep going back to him
because Beggars can't be choosers right
now and like a big part of this is going
to be if the Niners if the Niners go and
seek out a trade partner and they work
something out and then Jimmy's not
amenable to a contract adjustment the
whole thing was a waste of time for the
Niners so it's going to take both sides
you know if Brady had retired Albert huh
if if Brady had retired
Tampa wood made some sense because they
the Bucks have become so
the bugs have become sort of of Brady
right like the way that they run their
offense there's so many things specific
to Brady
and who would be better to succeed Brady
than somebody who lived in that Sphere
for three and a half years and who
understands the way that thing works you
know so I think Jimmy would have made a
lot of sense for Tampa if Brady had
retired and I think for Jimmy in general
like the next two to three weeks are
critical because in two to three weeks
he's going to be cleared to fully
practice again and I think that both
Jimmy and the Niners right now what
they're hopeful of I don't think they
think anything's gonna happen in the
next few days but what they're hopeful
of right now is that over the next two
or three weeks there's material change
to someone's quarterback situation
whether it's they get to Camp Seattle
Atlanta whoever it is Houston like gets
to camp and their quarterback situation
isn't as good as they thought it'd be
where someone gets hurt like the hope is
is Jimmy heals here and goes to the
final steps of his rehab
someone gets to camp and over the first
couple of weeks of Camp their situation
changes and they haven't needed the
position
let's say DeShawn Watson's suspended
today
let's say it's eight games yep then what
happens from the NFL's side of things
and the commissioner's side of things
I I think
my guess would be they wouldn't fight it
and I know that sounds crazy because
they've been so like they've very
forcefully gotten word out there right
and the reason the settlement talks fell
apart is because they were assistant
insistent on a year and now they're
seeking something more than that which
is an indefinite suspension which under
the CBA is banishment right like it's
like almost like he's not an NFL player
so the NFL has sort of been forceful in
letting their stance be known why would
they do that like if they know that
that's angering the U.S District Court
Judge Sue Roberts why would they do that
they do that because they think things
might be going the other way and maybe
they don't want to fight another round
on the back end and so at least it's
known out there now what they were
seeking
the biggest problem that the league has
now if it does come down to be six eight
ten games is they negotiated this
process two years ago at the union this
is the first high profile case and what
are you saying if in the first high
profile case you're completely
undermining the process that you just
put in place especially when that
process was driven by a lot of owners
like remember how remember Dan you
remember how angry Jerry Jones was over
the Zeke Elliott thing right like he was
really and and and and the whole premise
of Jerry's argument and a lot of other
owners arguments at that point was why
are we in the business why are we trying
to be the FBI here how about we just let
law enforcement take its course and how
about we let others lead us through the
process and if we have to Outsource this
maybe we should Outsource some of this
but we keep stepping on rakes when it
comes to these things whether it's Josh
Brown Ray Rice Greg Hardy Adrian
Peterson they've messed it up so many
times the whole idea of negotiating that
thing two years ago was take it out of
our hands so nobody and point the finger
at us anymore so I I think the way for
the NFL to have its cake and eat it too
here is to get word out there that they
were looking to be really tough with
DeSean Watson here But ultimately this
is the process they put in place and
they have to let that take its course
always great to talk to you have a great
weekend Albert thanks for joining us all
right thanks Dan Albert Breer he used
the Monday Morning Quarterback the
mmqb.com and you can keep an eye on
everything that they report